so that was about metagenomic data
analysis and the next program that is
being offered this fall is biomedical
data science using python
so the demand for scale data analysts
and scientists who can derive meaningful
insights from biomedical data has never
been greater and that's where our online
winter guided training program on
biomedical data science using python
comes into play
in today's rapidly evolving world of
biomedical research the generation of
big data has become the norm every day
vast amounts of valuable biomedical data
is being produced holding the potential
to revolutionize our understanding of
diseases and pave the way for
groundbreaking medical discoveries
however the sheer volume and also the
complexity of this data presence a
significant Challenge and that's where
data analysis comes in so this
comprehensive program is designed to
equip you with the knowledge and the
skills that you need to excel in the
field of biomedical data science and
through a combination of practical
assignments live workshops and online
resources you will embark on a
transformative Learning Journey that
will Empower you to unlock the potential
of high throughput biomedical data
so now what the different types of
levels will include the bigger Level
Training Program serves as a very solid
foundation in Python Programming and its
applications to biomedical data analysis
we understand that not all of you come
from a bioinformatics background that's
why we'll also introduce you to the
different types of biomedical data omics
data that is being generated and what is
what the structure of this data looks
like and then we'll get started with the
very basics of the fundamentals of
python in the beginning
we'll start by understanding the basics
such as data variables control
structures and also we'll discuss about
functions and modules
then we'll dive into data processing and
cleaning using powerful libraries like
numpy and pandas armed with these skills
you will move on to the exploratory data
analysis leveraging visualization
libraries like matplotlab and c-bond to
uncover patterns and relationships that
are hidden within your data Additionally
you will gain an understanding of
dimensionality reduction techniques and
machine learning using cycle cloud
and as you progress to the intermediate
level you will deepen your understanding
of clustering and advanced machine
learning techniques specifically
tailored for biomedical data analysis
you'll explore clustering techniques
like k-means hierarchical clustering
spectral clustering using python
clustering packages like scikit and
cyber and you'll also learn about model
validation techniques and evaluation
Matrix for supervised machine learning
models furthermore you will delve into
the advanced machine learning techniques
like decision trees random forests svm
Lea
Uma and apply them to the real world
biomedical problems